[Music]
another episode of is it couples Cornish
sure cheese we're going to talking about
what kind of oddly specific people do we
generally attract whether we're going
for them or not who just keeps showing
up at our doorstep based off of our
personality those hot girls man I mean
there's some they get attracted to me
that's what kind of women well they use
Steve to get to you honestly I don't
know if I have it I can spray them off
like I don't yeah i don't think there's
a type a woman that's attracted to you
know after the breakup video the flood
gates have been opened and i have been
receiving a very interesting range how
would you say from large ladies in
lingerie and gay guys that try to make
me gay so aggressive gay guys in largely
yeah yeah in very large ladies how do
they find you on instagram we should
have done opening our da no I mean
there's yeah I mean there's like normal
you know Norma is in like [ __ ] there's
cute girls - I just think it's way more
funnier when I'd say that I see that
these gay men are like naked and they
just have an apron like tied around
their waist because I called a story
about closeted like Muslim dude that is
like super devout religious and he
messaged me and he was like hey I know
you're like stray but I could cook and
nothing but an apron I could treat you
better than just ever did and like yeah
he should try a little harder because if
he knows you're straight he should try
to get boob implants like easy charter
like I want you to try liking and he's
like if you stay here you can live in my
apartment and we can I'm like damn dude
the dress is amazing
was it a nice-looking place like like
what Nelson's I don't know maybe I can't
even do it does your kitchen have an
island so most I'm finding that the
women who are reaching out to you are
they like your content oh well in the
DMS yeah who else would come chasers you
get cloud chasers nah dude okay look
here's my number one that I've been
getting for over like 20 [ __ ] years
non-stop won't stop it's white dudes
that like hip-hop music and think they
like black girls so they want to try a
little bit of caramel because I'm just
half black and they can go in without
getting too deep because they really
want to hip hop honey but like I'm just
enough got it wow that's specific white
guys who like hip hop yeah what do they
really like hip opportu anything's going
Oh school hip-hop new school they like
rap all that just just white dudes that
are in the black culture like I got more
clout chasers from tinder than I did
from DMS did you connect your Instagram
so you're tender
yeah I didn't do that so we were you
like I listened to Korn
all the time they were like no she's
light-skinned good enough yeah like it's
like they just I think they just wanted
to date like a black to almost reverse
racism where they're like I just need
you to be black that's it and like she's
checks out
you know what I think those I think they
find the attractive of course but yeah
but yeah I mean very like superficial
reasons am I good or am I good but like
don't I'm saying those are in the
overwhelmingly because I just had
another one like two months ago at a
convention catch on like okay cuz I got
my job I'm like ideal nationally with
like all of the venues and so there's
this one guy that he like kind of has to
report to me in to San Diego and then
we've been talking for like months and I
was always kind of a [ __ ] to him and
then because his work sucked okay
whatever and so then when we met up at
the convention he was exactly that type
and now this dude calls me all the time
for like literally no reason he'll send
me emails for approvals for [ __ ] that I
don't even need to approve like he just
all right up my butt and I had to call
him the other day and he was like yeah
no better way to start my Friday than
talking with you and almost like that's
cuz you like two o'clock wait yeah is he
like yeah I got your Tupac on vinyl
no but he does like old-school hip-hop
and it's like the same it's to say
that's exactly what I attract all the
time how yeah where is it the
underground hip hop heads a lot of
underground my pop not like me goes kind
of hip-hop
ya know usually the underground hip I
don't still like NWA like does that
didn't you did well I guess people did
yeah these coming straight from the
underground yeah no I know but some of
that stuff is so corny I don't know I
think it's more nostalgia for me so like
I know you're rockin so yeah I used to
listen to NWA like junior high in high
school are you attracted to me a little
bit Bose a little I'm a little
intimidated because I'm so attracted to
you
it's like the girl version of the boys
but no no I don't even think it's like
great music it's just that it's it's got
that nostalgia where I'm like oh that
takes me back to this time one time it's
you know it's just funny that people
thought that that was hard back then
that's what's crazy to me
you know what's funny is that some of
their songs are like don't smoke dope
right exactly
don't smoke weed we we eat it for dopes
and then later it Snoop Dogg's like a
smoke coach every day every single
[ __ ] day to do Nicki all men and
women all species of human no I don't
know you honest you're like type in your
DMS I love a type that continuously it's
like that specific type that keeps
hitting on me I will say that I had a
lot of older white men start a
conversation in Spanish to me tortillas
she also gets a bunch of broken English
Indian dudes energy yes isn't that
everyone done
that's like every woman I think you know
what it is is that when I like somebody
like I like funny guys and so like I
just hone in on a person and then I'm
trying to trap them and so I don't even
see the people that are coming at me
like I don't even even if you were
getting hit on yeah even if people treat
you like a hooker at a craps table you
[Applause]
take that oh you got a fly on your face
that flies attracted to Joe I attract
flies I feel like all the guys that are
attracted to you are really into anime
yeah well they're really awkward people
and then there's a lot with broken
English I mean you're basically an anime
character yeah nation guys from Asia
freaking yeah kpop lovers guys you like
anime guys who like ugly feet I think I
think I feel like I am the example that
people who have yellow fever go for love
anime that are in love with you
really are they white there you go I
cannot confirm or deny hmm they're white
that means Irwin and I cannot confirm or
deny but they do love anime
yeah and I know I don't know a lot of
people like anime now it's not just
geeky white guys there's a lot yeah
there's a lot it's a everyone likes
atomizer agents even like anime now yeah
there used to be just for white girl
what kind of people are attracted to you
hotties mostly and not nannies with
bodies oh yeah usually honestly it's
usually people that it was always people
I worked with always or when I did
improv yeah people who saw me in my
element doing my thing do you think
that's what's hard about it is that like
it has to do so much was like who you're
just around mm-hmm like I don't know if
it's so you're around a lot of old white
guys that want to say oh that's a
waitress yeah
the table and they're just like oh come
on stops muy bonita and I'm like oh god
sir nobody in English even sounds like
hi how are you you're so pretty yeah
don't you just can't do it yeah cuz I'm
kind of like Nikki - or like if I was
being if throwing advances that in
person I wouldn't even be able to see it
but if it's dm's I'm like you're
messaging me yeah yeah I don't know what
for maybe something else there is a lot
of do's to try to get me to leave Steven
my diems or like he he's gonna die soon
like what the way he doesn't drink water
like he's gonna die like you need
someone that's gonna be able to protect
you so there must be JK fan yeah exactly
they try to take any information that
can grab and then I'm gonna try to use
it like if I was your man I have a drink
with lots of water I would drink that
water for you babe I'm very hydrated you
guys go ahead and let women control you
it'll work out great for you trust me
right they love that [ __ ] they love it
when you're gonna talk to me yeah they
love it when you do literally everything
that that they want with no resistance
that [ __ ] can you imagine them coming to
like a mean green whatever and they're
flirtatious move to you is drinking out
of a bottle of water she's still gonna
notice this oh man look at this look at
this I drink water Nikki the whole you
just get closer and closer I feel like
if I'm so blind though to advances that
I only know that these are the women
that like me because they're sending
pictures in bikinis or something yeah
then I'm like blatantly they don't send
you this [ __ ] they're like yeah I'm like
a conversation maybe just just the most
forward ones yeah we just had a big mood
episode by the way should check out on
our podcast big mood but we just had a
big moon episode where we talked about I
don't know it was oh is what when Julie
was on were we talking about like
evolving like in
and I remember like in high school I was
like overweight braces goth like you
know some guys always like my best
friend they never liked me and the guys
I had crush on always wanted her if
there were ten guys in a room they'd all
want her nobody would want me so I just
got used to being like one of the guys
like I was like you know they all want
her and I'm just a freaking asexual okay
but then something happens some are
going into junior senior year I can't
remember what year it was but I lost 20
pounds and my braces came off and I
didn't dress as Goff anymore
it's the third active all of a [ __ ]
rom guys super nice to me and I just
thought well dude senior guys are way
nicer than junior by Hammacher I was
like God they mature so much in those
years no likes they become gentlemen
yeah dude before I knew the key so
unlike our colony Scouts days we
wouldn't really all hang out that as
much like I used to hang with the guys
mostly and so we would all like [ __ ]
around with Nickey and stuff and I
always thought that because Nikki looks
like Nikki looks that she was kind of
dumb and not like a bimbo yeah like I
didn't know her enough so I was just
prejudging her ologies always put me in
these really hyper sexual roles yeah
right so that's what I thought Nikki was
like I thought that she was like
airheaded a hot chick who had an easy
life right and then I like married her
and found out she was an airhead hot
chicken ahead and easy no you showed me
you showed me a picture of you in high
school dude and I had a Eureka moment
that blew my [ __ ] brain open on that
picture by the way is it the one with
the brain yeah you know what she looks
like you know that scene I think in
Finding Nemo where the girls tapping on
the glass she's the one that kills fish
yeah Nikki looks like she would bully me
I'm obsessed with them and I'm just oh
my god so yeah so that's when I was like
oh my god you were cool like you that
was cool well no you were like one of
the people you were you were not a
surgery were you were a surf you were
the blue collar you were not a noble's
person yes so though so the ten idea
real chances of human being oh thank you
I appreciate that so much
so always you were the popular kid I was
[ __ ] well I was 5 there because of my
personality the hall isn't like hot
popular totally popular because I was so
cool yeah call me
[Music]